hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to night lights now Night
Lights is an adorable game with a very
very unique game mechanic that I've
actually never seen before I saw a very
that's so cool oh wait no this just
showed it okay so notice how there's no
gap there I can't go down this ladder
right I'm mashing the button and I do
nothing okay so you hit dad and it turns
on that light and then suddenly the path
opens before you because the lights in
this game or at least some of the lights
remove like they just remove material
and I'm not sure what kind of
metaphysical [ __ ] is going on to
make that happen
but suddenly it's here and it's solid I
mean I'm sure someone will come up with
a lore explanation of why this is
happening and how this could possibly be
good for the universe just lights
absolutely destroying anything and then
it just rear bearing whatever like
someone was actually affected by this
line there's a lake and just we appeared
later cool okay where am I going oh I
know it I'm gonna is this guy's just
gonna rise magically out of the ground
please tell me it will God uncomfortable
for that to be stuck permanently
underground like that can you imagine -
that was a person what am I doing here
wait wait why didn't it yeah what
happens to me let's just go this is my
skeleton actually I'm like 90% bone here
okay oh we got rid of a wall wait was
there a wall in the way probably okay
what is this man okay all right I'm
gonna mmm
nice oh it's so cool oh it's so cool I
love the art style oh look at that look
it hello Hootie what you hooting about
over there
stop hooting at me I'm trying to solve
puzzles x + Yi ok so I know what I gotta
do a little bit I gotta create a path by
which I can get this box out of there
maybe probably I can climb oh that's so
nice
well the box is good the box is just
plain old gone alright I see how you
work ok I see I see what's going on here
ok alright so it just slips into another
dimension that's so weird I mean I know
there's a trick with like layers and the
such as like but still that's that's
pretty darn cool that's you gotta give
it credit as pretty darn cool
ok so I got it ok I think do for me oh I
got a flame oh I put the flame in the
box oh look at that any powers they're
so cool did I build all this by the way
that's another thing that I have kind of
a conundrum about oh the music school -
it's all games cool oh well well this is
a was a decision I gotta make oh I gotta
go get it first and then do the things
so nice so it's night and it's lovely
oh gosh do I take fall damage good this
is like it's so lovely and I fall and
break my shins oh the jacket bones is so
lovely
alright where am I gonna I'm gonna put
this in this box cuz that's gonna go
where are you going wait come back wait
no hang on I need I think I need you I
think ah jiminy Christmas
where'd you go oh you're coming back ok
I gotta hurry
sorry I thought that maybe oh that maybe
you were gonna be gone forever I'm like
a dog I just think once you leave like
you're gone permanently animal
no I'm so sad oh I could have put
something in here all righty then
interesting
well that box should have dropped down
okay hi cam there you are all right
this box is here but how do I get this
box up that goddamn hill now that that
is a question that is an interesting
question
mm-hmm wait a minute oh I saw I saw
I said whoa this is uh quite a box I saw
something
oh I saw something Oh uh-huh oh ho ho
indeed
Oh Oh No Oh I'm coming with you yes yes
okay keep going oh so close
all right cool cool cool cool what about
that other thing up there I don't have
two of those things I don't have two
things so I got a go here all right was
there like a bonus level okay all right
I'm gone man okay that's lovely
Oh goodbye material world oh look at the
way it's scooches oh it's goose is so
goosh this reminds me actually have
another game that I played I can't
remember what it was called it was kind
of some kind of like zombie game where
you actually control the plague night
terror something like that I can't
remember what it was I played it a while
back not like a while while back but
some while back yeah anyway just like
the art style this is kind of familiar
to me I got wet in the goddamn box I'm a
fool
that's why are you going though are
those doors like powered now or
something okay all right then
Oh skooshy jumpy blimey all right is
this gonna go up better go up huh it
goes up all right I don't know why those
doors are powered there like in verse
five nights at Freddy's doors they only
stay open when they're powered or
nothing through that portal why do I
gotta go back through that portal again
why don't we why don't I go oh I don't
think I need that box anymore
Oh what I okay I'm gonna be entombed
well please okay so I take this thing
can I take you I'll get you I'll get you
I'm gonna get you in a second there okay
alright okay so where is this all
leading me also beautiful place I'd like
to think that this is the forest from
Firewatch hmm and just somewhere else
somewhere else in this area there's this
a guy having a having a troubling
conversation via the radio which is what
fire watch was all about hello hi what
are you doing here how do I get up you
mmm okay I see I see what's going on
here
huh I see my big beefy brain can put two
and two together to know that I'm gonna
go no ok well that didn't work out
but now that I got a power duty I can
put this over oh is that gonna land on
my head and crush me gosh oh yeah long
oh well I got minor blame dab llege
see to pull thank you for that tutor
that is a well timed tutorial cuz other
what well it yes um I'm seeing real ah
there now it works it wasn't no I want
to pull it pull grab oh alright you
better not stop I'm pulling I'm Wang I
was Whangdoodle in that seat as hard as
I could Whangdoodle it no it needs to
alright got it nailed it hey it doesn't
need to be flat the same human fall flat
is box land off crooked
plunk in no work
conundrum as' okay all right well no oh
wait no that's correct I don't know I
panic so much about that little I'm
floating in the sky okay so what happens
if I break it what happens if I just
keep this here what happens if I stand
on this and squish myself am I gonna get
squashed Oh apparently okay never mind
that was that was anticlimactic what
does this do anything a door what that
oh squeeze me screws me now okay okay
all right I see how you do these aren't
exactly complex puzzles but they feel
satisfying because I feel good about
myself also the landscape in the
background that background is ah it's
good look at that sweet parallax
scrolling I love it wait I shouldn't
have been on here no no no I stupid let
me use my big boy I'm gonna jump on his
platform that down I wonder why it
didn't work before when I was over there
totally forgot why okay so once I get up
here
I put the Box on the I know you all
understand this but I'm explaining for
my own benefit so don't forget again I
put the box over on the thing no oh damn
it Oh too late
alright and then well that's all I got
to do right I think so I'm not I
represent sure but I think so my big
brain is telling me yuppers I always
trust my big brain when it tells me
yeppers wait oh I didn't think that was
gonna work I thought that needed a flame
thing love the way the music is pulsing
boom okay so whoa
the hell is that music stopped
mr. orchestra man you could kick it up
any time now it's a little weird being
alone in this dungeon okay well bye okay
I guess see ya
well I'll stay here forever then I don't
know if I trust you magic portal
underneath what could be a poop vent but
here we go
why not stupid cannon oh it's last
chance or one shot it's one shot once
the one light one shot which I need to
finish ah my brain my brain oh I have
the power
oh I have the power
look at me whoa all right now I got a
really think about this okay all right
so that turned that off this that day
that not good to be like that okay so
this coudair yes i pull you here no not
I'm gonna push you apparently not fair
like there all right don't worry my big
brain has been intercepted by a light
bulb it's kind of hard to conundrum
elate why didn't that fall
hey shift fall oh it's the wrong block
will this block okay I thought I was
gonna take a shortcut so it's a matter
of finding out which material is the
right material to be able to pass
through that's fascinating oh you just
showed me what godly powers I could have
had also you inserted something into my
brain which compromised my funkin
ability but oh that was good ah that was
so good
it was really really really good the
music the art style the game field
puzzles the uniqueness of it ah it was
good okay well that was apparently just
a demo oh man oh that's so cool though
that's so cool that's really cool
so I don't know much about this game
this demo is free I want to find out
more about it if I do I'll put a link in
the description below this is a cool
game it's just really really cool I love
seeing creative stuff like this the art
was adorable the music was really
immersive and the gameplay was really
fun it was fun and it taught it very
well
so thank you everybody so much for
watching if you want to play this for
yourself uh put a link in the
description below and I if I find
anything else I'll put that there as
well let me know what you thought down
the comments below did you enjoy it is
this a cool game or am I just stupid
those are not mutually exclusive
questions so thank you everybody again
and as always I will see you in the next
video
[Music]